probably the biggest unresolved question
coming out of fast X is where does the
franchise go from here most of its
characters are either in perilous
situations or totally missing we already
know that fastx is the start of an
overarching final story for the
franchise with Vin Diesel confirming
that a Trilogy is on the cards one of
the few people who has all been
confirmed to be in the next movie is the
villainous Dante as we get a glimpse of
his bigger plans in a post-credits scene
at this point we know that Dante wants
to take out everyone who has ever worked
with Dom's crew before however no one
expected that his next big Target would
be luke Hobbs it was seen getting a call
from Dante while on a mission Hobbs was
actually the one who put a bullet in
Dante's father during the heist and Rio
de Janeiro so he's firmly in Dante's
crosshairs Dwayne Johnson and Vin Diesel
have a well-documented feud after the
former WWE star joined the franchise so
his appearance here was a surprise but
it's clear that Hobbs is returning in a
big way and maybe with Shaw out doing
his own thing we'll get a Hobbs and Shaw
sequel as the next film until the sequel
drifts into theater is the future of the
fast franchise is a mystery